yeah hello and welcome to this video
yeah this will be just a short fun game
that I just found I think was yesterday
because I was looking at some game some
from from two club mates of mine who are
just playing um an open tournament and
as it turned out in the first round
there has been some huge upset where the
number two seed in this tournament the
Grandmaster
from from Latvia thank Reese to us Myers
he's playing the black pieces in the
game that I'm about to show ya huge
upset was that he lost his first round
game um guys rated 2479 so I'm pretty
good grandmas and he lost against them a
German amateur player with the national
rating of 1680 so this is the rating
difference of 800 points and a low
rating the difference was about 600
points so this players rating of the
Whiteside is what it was a bit high and
he low but however you take it 600 or
800 points it's quite some difference so
had let's have a look at this game how
this player only managed this huge upset
he played before and minus one c5 he I
know that he usually plays the petrov a
russian defense with with you five and
this was which sometimes as some yeah a
bit dull admittedly it seems that he
wanted to have a more a symmetrical
position with this is slowly into trying
to win this game
but here we got the notorious smith more
our gambit um
yeah an opening which I always thought
to be incorrect until I got this book by
American International Master Mark SMN
may amend the Mara which I did a video
review upon um last diem and this book
really am showed to me that this has
some practical chances this gambit yeah
well my um just took it and now I'm we
get a really normal position from this
opening but um okay Maya so it's not an
expert in the Sicilian he played this
petrov on its life and still that is
amazing to me that he now played the
move on Bishop c4 sorry white smooth
Bishop c4 that he now played the move
Knight f6 which is pretty much yes
something like a beginner's mistake
it's very well known that this move is
some is not good in this position and
this is simply because White has the
very powerful reply e5 which is the
white player obviously ya know about and
plate and this immediately opens up the
position and sets like some concrete
problems in fact just to show instead of
Knight f6 blacks main options are a6
which um actually prepares Knight f6 we
will see why that a six move has some
relevance in conjunction with Knight f6
Oh black and play b6 which is also
pretty normal setting up this small
skinning and center of course I mean for
like Bishop g4 check gets punished with
the Knight Bishop takes f7 okay Knight
f6 and now this e five move so let's go
through through the lines what
immediately clears that like cannot take
with a night as this would check would
lose the Queen
so after be 5 you can take with the
parlor it can move the the night
basically not g4s probably the
relatively best defense after whiter
should take on d6 this is better than a
6 which looks good at first sight but it
turns out that black has got some play
against this Bishop this is one point
[Music]
this kind of idea is really annoying for
white ok but this is not down so
interesting in regards to the game
better seems to be it takes the six end
of the Queen takes and cancels with a
possible Knight d5 White has a very em
dangerous initiative it's simply an open
position where I've got this development
advantage so this is tons better than
the game for black okay I'm on the game
of black play I'm the Grandmaster took
on e5 check now why it takes on d8 and I
takes the 8 yeah here can hear that's
also the move our King takes d8 but
there's some nice g5 and it's all its
this is also quite hairy for black even
this you can argue as this better than
the game but I don't know Knight e5
serve the only try here with the
possible continuation of this should be
5
you should be 6 there's no other way to
protect this and check if can something
like this where White has very very
strong position for the two pawns
because the triple pawns are just a just
so terrible
it's just hinders black and white has
got the strong bishops down
okay you went night xt8 which is far
more natural move and now night b5 yeah
yeah like actually has the chance to
bring it around
I need to switch that off he actually a
black can't lose and two moves with a
very very funny sequence King D 7 which
is really often played in blitz games
where people simply don't calculate
lines sometimes just play move check
after this
checkmate it's an immediate checkmate
it's quite funny okay King b7 is of
course silly but you cannot come a c7
which is the threat with 96 also because
white can simply take back and grab this
rook now so what is blacks supposed to
play yeah there's actually only one move
to to save the rook and this is to move
it this doesn't look look too great
okay let's let's move on 95 yeah with
the simple but defective threat Knight
c7 checkmate and um yeah what's what's
black supposed to do plate ecigs now and
yeah here White has more than one
promising continuation in this mentioned
book may man de Moura SMN actually M
recommends the move Bishop to f4 which
immediately eyes this this rook on b8
and he states that he did a very deep
analysis of this position cosmic with
them some computed assistance and came
to the conclusion that this move should
be clearly better for white this whole
line is actually really a disaster it's
amazing that this is the Grand Master
allowed this okay but Bishop f4 was the
move recommended in this book vadym in
this game the white player always
remember it's an amateur player
about the rating of 1700 he didn't know
this this recommendation and went for
night C session which isn't bad either I
mean look at this position of black skin
so we should be three and now white is
simply threatening Bishop c5 checkmate
it's a quite quite tragic comical
position here of blacks pieces um yeah
this checkmate threat it's very tempting
of course and now black played b6 which
is basically the only move you can also
look at and this is some fun line also
look at King d6
after which yeah white is very close to
to forcing a checkmate bishop and for
threatening some huge discovery checks
here right h5 check b5 check yeah now
black needs to yeah go back and give
away the be a drug so so something like
check something like this and of course
it's it's it's basically winning four
whitens and extra exchange and blacks
position is completely without any sort
of coordination but the front line also
is if it white
if black goes to to c5 then there's an
immediate check mate check coming up
check check check and check neat admit
yeah very nice and it's completely
forced after after the King goes to to
to c5 okay so
this is some what would happen if black
would play King to d6 he played in the
game we mentioned it was better b6 yeah
here white of course has some choice I
mean I didn't do a very deep analysis
here from alternatives white can also
think about just canceling short this is
actually what I think SMN is
recommending and now in his book and
this game him the the white player went
for long canceling which isn't yeah
illogical or bad either I mean it
immediately brings a look to to the
default and blacks position has sound
not at all easy to to defend yet this is
also what we'll see immediately now what
what black now should do a some he
should probably play the MOOC the move
rook to b7 I think this is maybe even
the only move it's of course not the
most aesthetic looking move ever but you
need to do something against this some
invading night
a possible continuation and probably a
logical one is wide retreating to be
five I mean you cannot cover this piece
in any way going back here and now black
playing Knight to d5 returning a pawn
and that I'm not sure if white has
anything else then then now getting the
pawn back I mean you don't really want
to because you open up the c8 Bishop I
mean this kind of this kind of scenario
you open up the c8 Bishop and sort of
free blacks position a bit but probably
you don't have anything anything better
it's hard to get get around this d5
Knight
okay so white would would take it as
mentioned and now probably f6 look H to
d1 yeah this is just a sample line don't
claim to be a check I don't claim to be
that this is that this is a perfect
perfect line but this seems a seems to
hold for black at least for the moment
it's not it's not fun to play but it's
not losing immediately and you must say
I'm what not losing immediately is a
person occurs an accomplishment in this
position because look what what's
happening I mean he now played the
Grandmaster not played Knight to d7 and
yeah this is not really nicely played by
him by the amateur player he played
Bishop to f4 which is just just the best
move in this position it covers the five
night but also
really puts this bishop on the critical
diagonal and it's pretty much lost now
this position I mean blackest without
any any defense here 97 none already was
the losing move here you can look at
various tries for defense on what he
played its Knight takes e5 but what is
actually the threat to that that white
might have let's say a black make up
some some 0 yeah he does there's nothing
what what is the problem then white
would cook Bishop to b5 and this is some
now very very annoying
what should should like do now you take
on d5 I will show that later but let's
say you goes here then there's this this
need move check sorry to pick a check
check check and this is checkmate after
Bishop b5 coming so let's say this check
check check Nate yeah quite nice we have
we have quite a couple of fun checkmates
now oops sorry
I pushed the wrong button here so this
was Bishop f4 and I was just thinking
about what what would happen if black
does nothing so this was the game but h6
Bishop b5 this was the move that is so
problematic if black now takes we've got
this this coming up f6 yeah what else
there's simply simply no other move
widest at least threatening 95 but okay
let's say I have six I was just
illustrate check this idea it's also
quite funny you don't see this too often
but should be a check which is covered
from c7 and now at the end be eight nine
is hanging so wide wins the piece with
an overwhelming position yeah this was H
six of course not a move that makes
terribly much sense but I just wanted to
show what what would happen if black
does nothing or does it react in any any
sort of way another try which is maybe I
don't know maybe a bit bit tougher to to
defend as to to UM to defeat this I look
to b7 e attacking this night um yeah it
doesn't really help as well but maybe
maybe this was better I don't know we
should be seven Bishop e6 this is a
problem what does this group doing now
yeah something like shank this it's just
a winning endgame yeah black is black is
pretty much done pretty much lost here
after all so after this this Bishop a6
what I wanted to show is Luke to deviate
where 95 isn't isn't bad at all but
you've got some some fun alternative en
route change this heaven check this was
also a funshine that then I looked at
King here check yeah and now there's
rook d7 coming let's say something like
this
check check
no it looks a bit it looks tricky so on
let's say I'm yeah up like what would
move the King now let's say here then
chief reign 1998 King here and rook the
8th is a quite fun way to to finish
black checkmate with very nice mate the
two bishops doing the job
alternatively King to UM into b8 check
there's this check and King a haters has
already known
[Music]
so I'm no movie really yeah there are
some some real funny lines leading to
quite nice checkmates okay so we were at
this position and now what like tried a
CT took on d5 and Bishop takes e5 simply
yeah and now the the problem is simply
again those those kind of moves are an
issue but also Bishop d6 he played now
I'm Knight to c6 which is some yeah I'm
not better worse than anything else
check we should have said Bishop e6
check and now I'm King to d7 and now
something quite curious is happening
I'll show what happened in the game we
should g5 check King e7 a black doesn't
have any other move why he gave the
check again and now black went to f6
which is quite funny because he many
could he could play King d7 just
repeating the position and then it's a
question if the white player really um
yeah I would find the winning move I
mean it's not so difficult but there's
also a chance that white being almost
800 points lower than his opponent um
yeah what would just take the wrong I
mean and have a point it's better than
losing so I'm quite quite um stunned
that black didn't do a king de 7 I'd
hope that maybe the white player was was
thinking okay a draw against the
Grandmaster it's not bad I probably
managed one in my life and I'll take it
and maybe he doesn't find the winning
continuation so I'm well back plate as
mentioned teen f7 I but I must show of
course what would happen after King his
own and if white would would now play
the right move and this is Bishop to
check g3 check
King is heaven only move and then just
looky one this isn't too difficult I
guess if you give this white player the
position he would he would probably find
it but you never know I mean you're
sitting there playing a grunts them a
grant masa and you know you you got him
in a way but you need to find it and and
you never know um but okay this is so
this is winning now black has really no
moves this sets up Knight d5 check and
yeah what should like do this there's
really no no move you could try to
escape here but this change is answered
by by an ID a check and yeah white here
can at least take the exchange of course
but there's probably even something
better you should be 5s for instance a
really a really strong move here with
ideas like just to show it Bishop d7 G
loop takes d7 again check yeah and now
check this isn't an extra exchange but
an extra piece which is much easier to
win so white would win relatively easily
but okay keep in mind we had this
position and here white played we should
be five he didn't find it in this
position check and well why not go to
the seven and try to get a draw I don't
I don't really understand
okay black played King f6 and I think
this is even easier I mean for Y to find
this what is now winning because now
white can simply chain ID a check King
to g6 and and grab this and well this is
this is easier than looking one don't
you think
well um now we played Bishop to c5 the
problem is also after
after this year it's not just an
exchange there's rook d8 coming and yeah
this is now I'm really embarrassing like
only has one move we should a six to
avoid further losses but this now has
some yeah awfully displays the night and
after 96 for instance this also this pin
here so black cannot move the bishop
yeah he tried Bishop to c5 to which
white just drop back the Bishop rook
takes and Bishop b5 nicely keeping the
initiative yam bishop please have
nothing else and rook d7 yeah and now
I'm it's really over black hood could
just resign here and actually in them
it's point it's possible that you
actually resigned in the in the game
file that I pulled from the from the
website there are two more moves here a
six by black and Bishop III check and
now it's 1-0 White is winning a blood
back resigned I'm not sure if this
really was played sometimes the last one
are two moves where were played out on
the bottom just after the game was
finished like okay if you would play a
six hour play Bishop d3 but they were
not really played I'm not sure this move
a six really doesn't make much sense to
me she can play this you can easily also
resign because everyone would play but
should be three okay so a fun game where
a rating difference of 800 points
against the Grandmaster was overcome and
yes always I always like to see and
watch those games where there was a huge
upset because it simply shows that it's
always worth fighting and trying to to
do something that you really didn't
expect to be able to do
and lots of shows that if you want to
beat a stronger player you um yeah
usually much better off with playing
some some active aggressive set up then
with some I don't know slow and then
passive kind of play of course it was
lucky for the for the white player that
um
- actually played this Knight f6 mover
just really bad but okay you need to
White has risk something with the Smith
more random that ya got whoops got
rewarded for this or yet just kicked
over bottle him and he got rewarded for
this yeah I hope you enjoyed this this
fun game and yeah I'll be back soon with
with new videos